los ciudadanos rusos lo van a tener más
complicado en el futuro poder entrar en
territorio europeo porque los
cancilleres de la Unión Europea han
apoyado que se suspenda el acuerdo de
visados que mantiene la Unión Europea y
Rusia desde 2007 una solución de
compromiso que se ha llegado entre
aquellos países que pedían una
prohibición total a la entrada y entre
aquellos que temían que está prohibición
pudiera provocar que se aislara aún más
al país esta medida Aún se tiene que
aprobar a formalmente pero cuando entre
en vigor los países tendrán que estudiar
caso por caso si se da una Visa O no a
una persona de ciudadanía rusa y aún así
tendrán que pagar mucho más dinero para
entrar en el país para el jefe de la
diplomacia Europea de josep borrell esta
medida era necesaria porque no
consideraba que ciudadanos sobre todo de
la élite rusa pueden entrar libremente
dentro de la Unión Europea para irse de
vacaciones o de compras mientras se
Libra una guerra en un Ucrania aún así
la puerta abierta especialmente también
para los países que escapen del régimen
de Vladimir Putin y también para los
estudiantes además los países vecinos
como los bálticos y también Finlandia se
podrán seguir reservando la posibilidad
de restringir aún más la entrada en sus
fronteras terrestres a ciudadanos rusos
por motivos de seguridad